the most important thing kay
is that we learn
from how we've responded to this
pandemic because it's not gone away
we're going to go on having
surges of illness
particularly affecting those who've not
been vaccinated for months and perhaps
even years to come
so for us at the world health
organization this kind of really cold
hard look at what happened is very very
useful we don't think it's relevant to
apportion blame at this stage we do
think it's right to learn
and one of the things that i want to
stress that i've
gathered from reading this report
is the absolute importance of
maintaining
people's understanding of what we as
individuals need to do in order to keep
ourselves
safe in the face of this virus
as well as having the right public
health in society we can't just rely on
vaccination we need more than that and
that applies in britain and it applies
everywhere else so it's very very
helpful report needs to be read needs to
be understood because the pandemic is
very much with us all over the world
right now
would you be um prepared to um
go further into talking about what we
did right and what we did wrong mr
nabarro
well absolutely i think that
what we're learning is that when you get
virus
starting to really spread in a community
the one thing that you must not do is to
delay
it doesn't help anybody
and
occasionally people think well if we
delay everybody will get infected so the
problem will go away because they'll all
be immune that also doesn't work
so i think what we have to remember is
be rapid and be firm as soon as you get
cases of the disease it doesn't mean you
have complete lockdown it just means you
need to be able to test and to isolate
and to stop spread and secondly lastly
just make sure everybody is part of the
response you know the virus is the
problem people are the solution so let's
engage people in the response and i
believe that
there's a lot to learn about what could
be done right at the beginning of a new
series of spikes of disease that set out
in this report quite clearly to say
those words again rapid and robust don't
wait
and involve people in the response
because actually we're the solution
we're not the problem yeah delaying
lockdown costs many thousands of lives
is what the report says
so i'm going to say to you
that each government has to decide how
it's going to deal with things you lock
down when the situation is really
serious before the lockdown you want to
have really strong test trace and
isolate programs organized locally and i
think one of the points in the report is
that at the beginning test and trace was
very centralized and that over time the
importance of a more local operation
with good sharing of data was absolutely
key so that there's many of those kinds
of pointers in those reports about how
the system can be made more efficient
but most importantly and i want to keep
stressing it to act quickly because if
you delay what we're learning all over
the world is that is that people suffer
we talked about test tracing isolate
there that was also criticized in the
report 37 billion quid cost here in the
uk and it wasn't fit for purpose
well of course every country in the
world has had to
work through how they're going to
quickly build up the ability to test
people for chronovirus and then to
isolate them and to trace their contacts
and isolate them and what's been learnt
in britain and in many other countries
is you can't just tell people to isolate
and expect them to stay at home without
any kind of financial compensation so
all the issues which are brought out in
this report about how you maintain
isolation are also there i think that if
if i had my way every country would do
this kind of analysis and would then
have quite a dense learning moment
so that the lessons can be applied
because i want to stress
this virus has not gone away it's
continuing to mutate it's capable
probably of causing all sorts of future
problems so why not let's all learn what
the experiences of the last two years
and make sure we've got them on board
for the years to come and then we will
actually be better able to resist it
it's not going to just go away if we
wish it away we have to organize through
our own behavior through the way in
which local authorities work and the way
in which central government works to
have a well-organized defense system
against this i fear very dangerous and
difficult virus it's a slippery customer
this one